[Music]
all right you guys take number it's you
let's try this again it's a good morning
happy Monday although jazz you know yeah
we had a big restart of our systems here
this morning and erekt aid to the rescue
no blame Persia any way around we've
we've officially come to that point yes
hi guys Persia here Ritchie's joining me
and today we're playing some greed fall
hot off the presses
you know it's an action RPG it's brand
new and it's set in the 17th century and
we got to do some you know world saving
things you know that's how we do and
what's up check yeah what is up chat
hello everyone crime and temper all the
people we see all the returning faces
and the new ones welcome welcome yes I'm
in already Otto Kong's like damn this
music is sweet right we thought the same
thing right away
alright so let's cut to the game screen
we're starting fresh new file now you
know the pride in me is like why not
likes you all the way but um you know so
we can actually get some good gameplay
and capture in here okay for the crowd
for the viewers so yeah I'm actually
excited to check this out we do do you
remember that trailer that crazy when I
was talking about that like was cool and
confusing it I'd had a lot of questions
but like I wanted to play right away
exactly like there was a lot going on on
the trailer the combat style looked
really fun and like kind of fighting
game asks a little bit yeah I was like I
definitely want to check this out
yes yes the chin a tiny bit lower oh yes
he's getting his portrait done wonderful
beautiful here we go yes
is that a lead-in to the create a
character that was really creative yeah
I like that
I was full-on ready for cutscene me too
so I did hear they have a lot of options
for customization which is just
wonderful
Oh at first I thought that thing was a
sideburn but looks like some sort of
scholar mark Oh interesting everyone's
got have it it must mean something
important
mm-hmm so these are all presets choose
different faces all right face choices
all right hey don't thank us temper
thank Eric day for fixing our audio it
took like under a minute he was like
boom yeah seriously and he like ran back
into the meeting and I was like Eric to
save the day all right
oh the hair yeah although this is the
17th century so it's all probably gonna
be pretty modest cool though a lot of
options yeah what's cool he was fine
although I did kind of like this little
braid thing going on here chat what do
you think the braid the bob the long
hair let's hear it all these choices you
know I'm so glad that like thick
eyebrows are in now cuz back in the day
when I was in high school you know the
really big dinner the better right you
know they do it yep like this horrible
there's a naturally hairy human being
[Laughter]
she doesn't look too happy she's like
yeah me too I mean are we ever happy to
get our pictures taken or in this case
paint portraits yeah oh my god
whoa looks like a Fire Emblem character
great I think I'm gonna go with that one
Otacon says go for the Bob it's a little
longer but I think that oh cool he
change the color to nice that wasn't you
looking every time I scrolled back
around to this side of her face I think
it's a beard something to consider
versus thank you Eric
yes yes thank you Eric the savior
thanked a new hashtag all right what
else you got starting classes magic
warrior or technical um all right so
from what I saw in the trailer 1 million
person I want to do like the magical one
because they look like they had the
coolest like combos and like let's do it
yes go with the magic life well there's
the tree so I have one point so I really
have to decide where it's gonna go right
so we got rank agility willpower
Oh increases maximum MP and spell
duration no I think we're definitely
gonna have to go I think we have a good
base for magic already kind of who
increases the power of all spills oh man
we only have one point says gopher nope
yep Daniel says magic that's our that's
who I yeah that's what we picked there's
a little bit of a stream delay here you
guys but we will try to take in your
recommendation so I'm between willpower
and mental power it's good mental power
I feel like that that is we all need a
little bit of mental power then I wish I
had a skill tree like this my mental
power would be maxed first alright cool
so we've increased all of the power of
all the spells alright great
talents ooh charisma hmm
Oh interesting reduces merchants prices
slightly okay
charismatic that's Rick that's cool I
like that vigor hmm yes this is on ps4
history it is available on Xbox and PC
also if those are your preferred
consoles and or platforms excuse me
craftsmanship class okay wait what's
intuition that one picking that's fine
this is the 17th century so you know the
black think we're gonna have to get
around using a lot of lockpick Hampshire
all right and then science notions right
potions magic these things are working
on all right so where are we going you
guys where are we going
I like potions myself what about you
yeah I think that fits in with our magic
theme here yeah
all right we've done it we've created
characters that's it boom that's game
just a few minutes you better come
correct
RESP CT we have nearly finished
oh I sound nice and proper et is sorry
anyone needed me most oh oh cool yeah
they do your settings a nice course not
we were done
your cousin is nowhere to be found I've
searched the palace from sellers to
attics your uncle is beside himself he
was of a mind to paint the town last
night
don't worry that bar track them down can
we to learn all about it it's about time
your cousin took account of the
responsibilities awaiting him man my
family is in all kinds of mischief free
I know I'm just trying to get my
portrait done getting a selfie in the
17th century tell him that his painting
is bad and don't pay Oh what I mean he
didn't even get to my face yet will be a
easy switch commission right we must
continue this here we go
all right seamless nice our first steps
into the world go and say goodbye to my
mother all right for a moment real quick
I'm just gonna press some buttons there
we go that's everything io tactical part
interesting so that was square yeah I
don't want to hit anybody I'm not trying
to I'm not here for that okay
button checks here oh the tactical pause
I saw this in the trailer actually so if
you're battling you could do the
tactical pause which gives you more time
oh cool so like pick and choose your
potions or which technique you're gonna
use right like on the fly yeah all right
so I gotta go say bye to my mom I guess
right mission number one well yeah we
didn't get our painting done so that
would have been around that walking
here we go the day has finally come
do you see this magic in my hair you're
ready to roll looks like some training
and with everyone's battling out here
they're fighting words by word like that
all right you got this Persia attack
three times you got it
I like this music this is like this is
like old school battling music oh there
you go that looks like a shield
definitely got you three times bro
defend myself oh you would offense
anyway one more time that's great okay
stories we the sword I can fight oh I
guess this needed to happen because we
have to learn how to heal all right
tactical applause all right got it and
then I go to motion crime yes I knew it
sounded familiar sounds like Gerudo
Valley which I love
it's that guitar
oh you have lost house assign a shortcut
oh okay ah there we go
so oh come on it's a low one potion
wants me to bind it dr. Phil and the
chat says she needs to have blue hair
that'd be pretty dope we're colours like
that even an option Oh Oh chill bro
there you go there you go good block
relax parrot we're training
oh good lord I was figuring out my
controls dude I hate when they bleed it
into like the story like that
I remember Kingdom Hearts did that too
like you lose the spine they're like
good good attempt great attempt go fight
with honor
all right now he wants me to God oh okay
it's like no more Kurt okay can you use
shadow and light magic temporarily
freeze don't forget to pause for L 100
they want me to bind these guys you got
this okay I'll buy in the sale of the
techniques we'll be over here
action Oh X is dodged okay gotcha I was
kind of looking for a role option but I
wasn't sure um I think I want to oh I
can't bind those I was gonna bind that
okay here we go
I did a special move earlier
not enough adrenaline you got the Juke
about them breakdance right now there
you go I want to change my weapon oh
yeah we got access now there you go
hands and magic but however I can
totally freeze this his friends not
helping him now Armour the physical
armor level is shown with shields on the
health part okay use an impact weapon on
certain traps magic attacks ignore armor
out well here I was all hype about being
a magician gotta go back to basics
oh no we're still here we go
oh nice blog okay I was like there was
like one frame left and you blocked it
[Laughter]
running away from you oh they're scared
Gary time okay okay as you use a special
attack that inflicts a bonus damage
you've had enough now lose their balance
it's very time all right el two teas
okay that's not used earlier on accident
who wants to pay your hands on fire yeah
you're furious like alright I gotta beat
these guys down and then the train was
over if you feelin rusty are your bags
packed for the great departure yes you
know I get very little you're not angry
that I'm coming with you I hope ooh
we get choices am I happy Lee's going
wrong or am I gonna complain about being
shadowed by body garden mmm see I don't
understand my character enough yet right
like yeah sassy is this a part of me or
I guess this is where I decided right
it's up to you Persia you know what wait
it's the 17th century clearly I got
something going on with my face so I'm
gonna be grateful I got back fine I'm
back yeah
a party a few friends at your side in
unknown territory is a boon the old
school teacher is competing against me
by the way where is our future governor
hiding I was hoping to pop his skills to
the test as well I have no idea he had
plans to celebrate his departure last
night and we haven't seen him since oh
you went out already I should have gone
with him but my heart wasn't in the mood
for a celebration
the thought of bidding my mother
farewell it is never easy to say goodbye
but you should be going to see her now
oh man you're gonna hit me in the fields
Oh meet you in front of the palace then
we'll go on find Constantine together
very well
I'll meet you as soon as I've said my
goodbyes re okay now could we say
goodbye to our mother
go talk to mama I think we found her
what is this have you not bend or not
whoa I've asked a thousand times oh man
words we definitely need a cure for
something yeah mother I'm sorry I'm
having trouble getting used to your
condition
[Music]
come now let's speak of more pleasant
things I'm very happy to hear your face
what's up with the bearded lady it's a
scar we're looking into it tomorrow yeah
but whatever mama's got is worse yeah
maybe that's what's the common stop it
Island everyone's talking about yes but
the idea of leaving you behind alone and
ill dying my child there's nothing you
can do Autocar wild mom is very sick
yeah she's also like so really go find
this island might find a cure it's okay
I'm Marty [ __ ] no I can't
it brings me come has left on a mission
to heal her people come now it is time
for you to take leave here take this
with you maybe a key I thought it was
like it's all I have
with you know Dave Buell it's maybe the
last time we see mom I know right like
looking in real life
I don't even know if I'd be able to do
that I'd be like hey I'll get some
pre-emptive baths in the chair all right
I said bye to my mom evil now I have
this ridiculous hat Kurt yeah kofi
training when did you run in him again
very not game out um I believe it
officially releases tomorrow tomorrow
okay although I did see on their website
some mention of the day as well so it's
done hmm sorry green blood look but
definitely it's even definitely tomorrow
they'll be taking us that's a great
looking at I hope this island will keep
its promises was the Saint Constantine
first you were right maybe he is already
at the part he was so eager to leave
this will be quite the chore to finish
before our departure
oh yeah now that we've seen him side by
side I did all I could to persuade
nothing came of it all the parliaments
in fatigues me but this is your domain
no wouldn't say no to a little help of
course where is the supplier located in
the lower borås near the port right then
mm-hmm we'll put it on our list of
visits oh I can add people to the time
here we go
well we only have one option worthy of
joining our party that's mean he taught
us what we know so far
right exactly all right so we have their
main quest and then we also I've been
asked to pay visits to the bathroom a
and the bridge Alliance before
Parcher their dwellings are not far from
here we could go there first
very well do you think constants in
we'll be waiting for his next to the
[ __ ] I don't know but it is suddenly
worthy of inspection all right so let's
see we can either notify the bridge
Alliance ambassador about our departure
or or do that again and another spot
okay maybe that's like the second part
of the quest all right it's like he's
following us right yeah let's go Kurt
yeah
I've discovered a whole quarter reminds
me of Assassin's Creed okay oh wait
someone's trying to square up already oh
whoa stunned curtain hate you it almost
looked like you did
nice yeah there we go
that's good
Kurt held his own very good when it's
swinging but cool all my stuff and
equipments Journal codex lots of stuff
for now
oh I can leave some boxes uh yeah let's
just take everything let's go
Joker yeah I know curse
alright so gotta look the bridge you
know which I'm gonna assume and by the
water but we have to battle some I don't
know homeless people what those look
yeah they look at all sus they look more
than regular townspeople maybe they had
magic too or something so far Nestor in
the chat likes this game this game looks
dope like I'm still figuring up a little
combat system here but I like it so far
at least with this class I don't know
like probably where in the world am I
going this is a big world too I know I
haven't even left like home days yet Oh
a Prince's place but this is like Taurus
on fire I'm kind of just running into
the direction of oh the thing on top
oh there it is no yeah we made it by
accident
we forgot some loot on the right oh I'll
be back for it was that my name did you
would need Liggett oh you were given a
name into relations
those are great responsibilities for
someone as young as yourself but you
will bring honor upon your family and
the congregation of that I'm certain I
think I wanna bring my cousin
Constantine is taking office as governor
of New serene and I'm accompanying him I
had no idea you would be eating so
quickly awaits you
they say that it is a marvelous Island
please convey to your cousin my
congratulations and sincere wishes for
success you seem slightly hesitant
please tell me what troubles you a
rather unscrupulous individual has means
trouble
do people actually give Creed angel or
one the same looks like as you can well
imagine alchemists are our pride this
vulgar trickster casts dirt upon their
reputation and our own at the same time
in any city of the bridge Alliance beef
going on here but here I know respective
things I shall see what I can do but
make no promises my departure is
imminent
I thank you excellency yeah you know to
be variable of thinking is essential
there's not Kuwait's among races the
city center I really like when you're
walking around outside
the environment was really cool so far I
kind of just want to get going yeah we
are
goodbye Excellency like I said to you
mid time we're on a mission you here we
go oh yeah where's that loot though
[Laughter]
alright next order of business lead the
way
wait already that already daniel says
for an indie title this game looks
really great thanks for coming along
joining us on the stream yeah it's off
to nice humble start alright say what up
to serene good day excellency lady de
Sade to what do I owe the pleasure I
have come to inform you that my cousin
Constantine and I are departing for tier
four D on the hour here for you yes the
magical island did hear talk that you
had both received callings of Greater
stature allow me to congratulate you in
the hat's growing and Murat named
Leggett of the congregation you are
correct
excellency I thank you it is a station
of great honor that I am sure you will
feel with brio and panache Nasser asks
where's your car I only regret that your
departure is so sudden
really Oh to be presently honest with
you I was hoping to solicit your help in
a rather delicate matter don't worry
about it and perhaps I can take care of
your problem before my departure very
well a small group of damages dressed
like a villain yes I know I think we're
about to do some dirty work tolerates
the presence of all
within the city walls but these
particular non-believers threaten the
fragile harmony of this place oh man
heresy is not a crime in serene you do
know that but I'm sure that my uncle
would hear your arguments why call on my
intervention the Prince would indeed
give us his blessing but it would take
time far too much time for according to
our sources too much time sister Knight
this process you say to an enemy city if
your heretics are planning on boarding a
ship then they must be in the dockyards
I'll look into this and see what I can
do
we're on it I must be going yeah we out
farewell excellency may the light guide
you I want to throw some magic throw
some magical hands I don't like how he
said that hey the light guide you all
right I'm not really sure if there's a
map of any oh crowd there you go all
right current thanks
we're oh well oh no scary face you can
start by explaining to me why you refuse
to honor the orders agreed upon with the
guard oh there's been a misunderstanding
madam of course we're ready to one of
the orders in fact I've already had a
woman master-at-arms
oh hey again despite having already paid
he's just at the prize a skirt something
up this is inadmissible if you agree on
a sum you need to honor that agreement
I'm sorry madam I'm just an agent and
nothing is sue where's the fight hem
option I know right
enough talk alright putting your
business it's what we do immediately I
do know in the future we won't be
shopping with them oh this must have
been before the customer is always ready
to demand a second payment for this
merchandise that's right he told me that
their attendance seemed to be hiding
something when he passed the order and
so he must have thought the guard would
end up paying in the end whatever he
asked for no he said she said right
there sorry captain it's nothing
personal I'm only following orders class
following orders
makes one wonder which one of the two of
us is a coin guard second payment but
refused to reimburse the one that was
already made hey I'm not the one
demanding nor refusing it's my master
this stubborn fool is pushing same such
an epic description that you threatened
him offer a bribe or just threaten him
for free it is free would be economical
about this or leaf
well this is interesting he's just
staring at us with this this cost one
eye I'm not sure one of his eyes because
they're pretty weird red guards we're
allowed thank you do it yeah what do we
have to lose I think it does something
with my charisma the congregation of my
god assert my authority over station you
explained to me that your master forced
you to commit a crime that's regrettable
especially as you will be considered his
accomplice in xod hmm coming out with
the legal jargon you keep saying that
homeboy you're gonna get yourself
arrested
no jury's gonna I order you to return
the guard the merchandise without delay
unless you can't access to his home and
that you finish your days in prison beg
your pardon m'lady but you are not my
master discounts from this guy with your
courage that would stir up the muck
whatever is he talking about Kurt
your guess is as good as mine oh man we
gotta get out of here I don't like this
guy no more either ton yeah we'll be
back
I got people a beat up of my madness oh
man I just want to go fight some people
you should have threatened that guy
probably would have started a fight yeah
push that guy in the water
at your side
yeah alright we're waiting for him not
to be leaving yeah I've got things to do
the subtitles are a little small uh
zones controlled by other factions oh oh
certain places are forbidden here in
enemy territory I have to where I see I
said where a certain certain costumes
but gang colors yeah you're repping the
wrong set Persia where these about your
hat it's a 17th century no for real
though I need a map all over the police
no I thought somewhere here we go here
we go wow this is so I guess we have to
go here so that we can that seems like
the most pressing mission cuz it's
yellow great that might be the last
thing we have to do actually before we
okay just can i pinpoint this I guess
not but it looks like I just had to run
straight so we should be okay yeah
there's a little compass on the top that
seems that kind of help
wait oh oh I see I see it oh he's down
there yeah I tried to jump over the wood
do some indistinct
jump ball to the apex enemy jump over
everything okay here we go here we go I
promised the merchants and their prince
would be off before the tide you man
carry that properly that porcelain is
worth more than your life risk of the
face tattoos it's like ordering everyone
around
yeah I'm children we'd best to refuse
he's got the legit pirate hat I'm just
saw day the prince is nice I was named
you will soon be embarking on your boat
get it right he didn't come home this
morning I need to find him before
departure I hope nothing's happened to
him or he hasn't changed his mind the
tide does not wait perhaps he simply
celebrated his imminent departure with a
little too much and visited yeah he's
hung over somewhere we still haven't
found her now we gotta go find cabin boy
himself before the tide is he an
important member of the crew we don't
need him for sailing or navigation he's
only a cabin boy he must have simply had
a bit too much to drink in celebrating
his departure or are we gonna have to
make a decision leave him behind a year
has never won a fancy drink and it's
been two days since last he was seen
something bad has happened to him might
I ask you if you hear anything
could you report it to me I would like
to set sail with a clear mind that guy's
mascara game is strong Irene so hmm have
you just spit on gonna dip yeah more
small talk gotta go fine Constantine's
useless self oh look at him over here in
this alley somewhere
Oh at the tavern yeah okay I mean that's
where you find me relatable it's a
Monday okay
quest can be completed in several
different ways
interesting okay okay all right boys
let's get that Intel good idea what is
your pleasure information I'm looking
for my cousin his name is Constantine I
believe he was intent on celebrating his
departure last night there was indeed a
brawl broke out marks heaven was
shattered and now wants paid for the
damages I'm sorry
amongst the ran they had a young major
pretty hair down to his neck light brown
blue eyes quite the talker I don't
believe it of course II was there he's
the man I hope you've come to read great
oh no great shake down what kind of
damage are we talking about exactly a
good offer my furniture was broken into
firewood I piled up the lot over there
let me take a look perhaps it can be
repaired by God is carpentry in our
skill tree something similar was all
right I guess is in terrible condition
the fight must have been extreme that
bad fix that just some lame hmm I could
repair this if I have metal those ain't
gotta go get some love those cute like
right like like nudging you back in fact
that means no doubts
let's go get some dowels this looks like
alright craftsmanship allows you to
upgrade your weapons and armor science
allows you to create potions and jabs
Budin we should upgrade address science
who knew I need science so early let's
see
use the crafting table spin points in
the desired talents use pieces of
equipment do I I still don't have metal
dials though
all right does it actually show me where
I can find myself
I doubt well what's that question mark
down there an area of the map unexplored
point of interests merchants amazing
place all right it's that's gravity
I guess we might be able to fly there
this map is like a little maze it's open
like a bunch of alleys Oh
citizens i unlock in cutscenes
everywhere see the absolute pure all in
one elixir this potion heals all of that
men medicine back then musta been a
scary thing this yeah that's why I
started coming up with all this stuff
the cure-all
yes magic potion not yet but your
question like I was easy legitimate I am
so close to finding the cure but the
malla core isn't the only ailment
causing you to suffer not true they
don't miss out on this chance and give
yourself a healthy and energized life
enjoy super hyped about product yeah
everything absolutely everything except
the manticore of course that claying
said it is known that those in top
health resists the manticore best of all
Bob Jones reality it's just alcohol
[Laughter]
you avoid you are right
he's a deal I'm gonna take soon there's
a man that knows a good deal when he
sees lon hurry now there won't be enough
for everyone these are no doubt this
speech is well polished I even feel like
buying some thing this is a sidequest we
stumbled into a site honestly I needed
some metal dowels that's what we need I
was going to the merchant to see if we
can buy them there wait isn't he mad at
us is that the same one from earlier you
know maybe I should just ask that which
is large and very females or anything
I'll go back to threaten that old
merchant that's more Intel totally tired
of us while they were you able to repair
oh wait I haven't been able to send that
case I regret I don't oh man I can't
even ask you about that
yeah farewell goodbye we say half your
furniture for real too bad this is like
a pile of cookies if I had some metal
tiles okay come on Kurt trying to see if
they're just gonna be like out somewhere
door the talk business
mmm-hmm old warehouse okay okay there
this is looking good you know that guy's
just ill I know this okay no like oh
this crates okay good to know if those
little crates have the essentials the
pick-me-ups yeah we are on this side of
town where everyone is sick so I wearing
a mask yeah that's one of those
old-school like doctor ones they put all
the herbs like in the snout of it oh man
because they thought that we can protect
it from like airborne illnesses and
stuff like that oh okay let's see come
such a pleasure to see have you seen
anything to your liking I guess some
metal nails for me man these are all oh
all the weapons
wha-ho consumables and greedy
quest items aha you found them yes
hey repair the damage caused to a four
did I need any more
welcome have you seen I think it was
like repair that oh I have to go parent
I think there was like more than just
that one bench you saw that needed to be
fixed
freakin Constantine starting fights at
the bar or making me around through this
homeless alley oh no boy I know
alright alright
found the dowels yes I just want to get
on this boat get to this island and
sorry throw in some magical hands like
the training I could repair this if I
had something you do you do I swear it
just I could repair this if I had some
air we're there he thank you and
everything okay they're here craft level
oh yeah why cuz we have no crafting
skill so I need to get some crude iron
ore also so I should have bought two of
those things from them no rats I see I
see wrong track yeah you know it's the
17th century so they want you to
struggle no Amazon orders oh yeah you're
right
Otto Kahn says maybe use a crafting
table first wait I would it still says I
needed some iron though right
I couldn't tell if I had did he sell
some too I think I did see some in the
materials section
alright the homie purchase amounts
where's my money I got four coins so I
will I think only about two constantine
better pay me back yeah he's following
his messy trail of destruction spending
all my coins I saw an option to talk to
Kurt when you faced him I wonder if he's
like Navi and has like didn't tell about
like what you should do next yeah he's
yelling hey we can craft these bad boys
now I don't have a high enough level and
ah I see oh so they want me to make
something first
I'm office I do not know
oh boy let me go see you sure I like I
just shove that guy yes I definitely
need to use his vehicle oh wait why
haven't these skill points left
available key upgrade on the fly that'd
be cool oh yeah okay okay skills skill
okay tons of skills down the line man
there we go craftsman yeah oh I just see
it on the top right five four the next
point I'm on level one am I supposed to
go be people up and like the other
factions hey Kurt
we bought the metal dowels but she's
still like mmm if I had some middle
ground that's gonna be great do you need
something I can open that wound though
is that the awfully proud skill points
yeah I'm like I have the metal dowels
Chet help at first I was like okay maybe
if I build something small then they'll
let me like level it up right in theory
okay okay what do I have traveling suit
yeah there are not that one
I mean let me see it well they let me
reset my point uh I need a memory
crystal to reset the point I was gonna
move my point over man they got me they
got me okay
I have to be able to love lips no not I
don't want to even car was like is this
bench giving you trouble
okay I know I can definitely get a skull
point by leveling up a level five is
there an area I can go - let me go - uh
man they're making you work for it your
cell fix a bench I know what the heck
thinking I might have to level up
I only saw that one area where we
actually got to fight people is that
because we went to the other faction hmm
because if that's the case we can go
back to that side of town right and go
level up real quick or possibly do some
of these side quests not a few yeah
maybe oh they actually had an option to
display these on there yeah that's cool
there we go all right I guess we can go
back to this one since we since we kinda
already did the first time yeah all
right let's go unmask this fool then
some scooby-doo style stuff here finally
tempted in all honesty I haven't made up
my mind yet I want to be certain that
I'm not dealing with a charlatan in this
day and age I can't blame here look at
this
slick guy okay let's see ya a few
options Oh
to prove your good faith of course I
take a little sip every morning but as
I'm I'm a hundred years old
the improvement in my condition but if
it helps you make up your mind give me
just a moment
hmm boy her live I'm gonna need to see
you doing this trying to bamboozle you I
consider skepticism a remarkable quality
but in your case it's not skepticism the
blindness we need to steal one of these
potions and force him to drink okay
you're talking about it Nancy's father
any nasty side effects with this remedy
view we are playing on the ps4 currently
nothing but it's also available for Xbox
one and PC do we ask again are there any
nachos anything I will think about all
right so we've got you you'll feel
something uh yeah maybe we can get
someone to steal I'm sorry I'm afraid
can't like knock that guy's lights out
and just take a bottle one of these
passerby just like what up all right
Kurt you're the one who says we shave in
blood do you need something
yeah elaborate on your master plan not
your personal life Kurt
uh-huh oh gosh okay okay okay figure
this out figure this out
kurz raki
I got no one's face at all either I
would know what's gonna buy one yeah all
right so not happening oh I like her was
dug into what I was gonna say I'm like
waiting like maybe another customer will
buy one and then I could take it from
them no that's string it is the only two
options didn't make it available to
steal right maybe I can get someone in
here this is how I speak to my subjects
all right so maybe we can try another
quest where we have to like fight people
so that it can help us level up yeah
that'd be cool see some action we got a
little at the beginning but uh we're
both like Kraven from war here
looks like there's a lot to do this team
yeah it's full packed to the brim there
you go ciao Kurt oh wait oh that's him
you know thing over his head I already
talked about your cousin I know we're
working on it
[Music]
have you seen anyone wondering about
suspicious looking maybe clandestine
passengers take a look around there are
far too many comings and goings to spot
possible stove yeah try and get on my
ship I paid no attention to it
we did catch ourselves a smuggler almost
a while ago a smuggler maybe he could be
of some use where could I find him in
the port jails not far from the
warehouses why I asked you why this
sudden interest in smugglers you mind
your own business basketball that's
between me and Kurt yeah exactly nothing
to bother yourself about
I'm just curious coincidence be on the
trail of a couple of heretics your
excellency the same a couple of the
ambassador's of Ptolemies men have been
looking for those guys digging I don't
know about that of course
Cardinals henchmen are hearts of men coy
yeah do it
meanwhile I know everything help
feel free to carry out your own
investigation but you'll end up with the
same answers the port breaks just like
the warehouses
property of the North's no one else hmm
well we're about to yeah we'll see about
that
all right interrogate smuggler people
smuggle the Sailor mentioned he's a
captain Kurt like yourself where's that
ooh
Turkey there you go yeah I think right
that's a good man sir buy it now earlier
they're like watch out through here and
we haven't come across any combat since
we've been in this side of town
Kurt again yeah yeah you wanna fight
Warren
Know Who I am
now very well I'm going now we want to
fight they're just like hmm insist again
exception no very all right sure way to
sneak around cuz he's in there somewhere
we gotta be sneaky oh I love how she
opened the door
out of my way door so you can't okay
okay here we go
those hurt help out yeah Kurt wait no
guys wailing on him now where Kerr is
beating up someone else no I hear ya oh
okay you can take your time and drink
the potion out or what you die the next
bite you suggested he was like a potion
Kurt don't you underestimate me here all
right
there we go little lutein here
lock-picking level one I just pick the
worst like skills to start with I can't
take no locks I can't craft new doubles
we were so close to picking that - you
were like it's 17th century I think
lock-picking
I know do you worth it went into that
bill and we take a look oh here we go
we're going around those guards we go
okay okay Otacon this is why I suggested
lockpick
I swore tonight what do we pick instead
I forgot Oh
curations I think
drats well here we go we'll get around
there's always a way around yeah we got
a bill up all of our skills now it's
just making fun of us no it just looks
simply oh wait here yeah we haven't been
down here
okay let's see here I'll be taking over
for just a bit see if we can find this
guy and ask him some questions I feel
like we got close
I feel like I'm locked out Kurt has no
answers of course
luis is looking good
no we were out here before already
France
here's another ladder though
Filipa there was some combat but it's
sprinkled throughout like there wasn't
uh there was a few fights but not much
yet we're still just on some side quests
try to get to that combat and bigger
missions for now Persia back in the
building yes I am apologies apologies
alright so we snuck in right yeah I went
to another I went up another ladder
because that building we were in there
before didn't really have this one yeah
that's me something somewhere because
these guys over here even though if they
can't see me right now yeah they're not
great job they just kind of tell us them
go away I wonder what happens if we walk
back in front of them the other land
they're freaked out alright it has to be
something over here yeah I feel like we
were on the right track in this area
that's they're guarding something
I'm gonna go all the way down to like
where the front door is tempting I know
it is gonna happen if I actually says I
can't yeah I think this was the door
they were guarding wasn't it what hey
hey just a sip yeah this is decoration
nah they were guarding this story that
has to be take it oh whoops I thought I
did I press the wrong button I guess cuz
that's all that I really think at all
and I think I just backed out for a
circle climb out of doors yeah I need to
pick that lock oh right I remember now
okay whoa whoa camera things
yeah
hmm
all right I just want to see what are
you gonna say what do you bloom pauses I
wanted them to be like what very well
I'm going what are you doing yeah
nothing I'm just gonna sit there and
yell at us some more access to the
prison great what about going around
yeah clown we're gonna sneak in here for
sure there we go yeah alright alright so
we're gonna sneak in they got guards but
they also have bag doors I mean in
theory we could just climb over to this
yeah to there we'll find a way in I
think it looks like under are these
connected yeah okay okay so in theory I
might be able to get inside this one
there we go
Forbidden Zone ooh okay lots of doors
Oh
for a second I thought that was another
one
hey or what uh yeah go get teamwork
there we go got some money
teamwork makes the dream work is this
one mine am i a little low or am i
tripping um this one is okay nevermind
um I'm gonna check out upstairs when I'm
pretty sure that door over there was the
one we really want making some progress
even even got in a little fight here a
little scrap yeah we're still very early
in the game you guys there's a lot to do
no we do need to go upstairs okay
that was a whole intention we sneak
across yeah Otacon sneak mode yeah just
going guns a-blazing climb option was it
no I'm just being spoiled rats
a CoA out there
that's the master plan hmm what's that
door is that the one we got in from
earlier another one on the left with a
label on it it just takes us back
outside oh yeah okay we just win right
around them you're doing a terrible job
of guarding the area okay well it's a
series of warehouses it sounds like so
there's gotta be one with some answers
right one of them we have to be able to
scale the rooftops
take it over yeah we gotta get to the
roof okay so this is the balcony yeah
that doesn't meet over there
poop okay you know what next quest one
of these quests is gonna level us up I
still need to find Constantine yeah I
can't be a side quest can it easily
that's the main one yeah
just we ain't got no metal down KITT
excuse me citizen out of my way yeah I
wonder why it's probably just like part
of the story to go through there the
17th century of saw so many locked doors
I mostly just want to level up I'm not
even a level 2 yet but I need to go
where there are more enemies yeah right
now we have a lot of things to do but
they haven't really build up our levels
just yet if I can just level up and get
another skill point whoa there we go
mysterious dude in the alley
whoa oh whoa
well first you ask for it hopefully this
will get us Oh
any message time Curtis Curt is kicking
ass oh that's cool that's the positive
action yeah wiped out there we go some
money did
I'm almost level two now oh yeah okay
well we found the bad area that we can't
be in which is great right yeah other
side of town yeah so bring it on losers
he's a regular see Jeremiah now I'm like
who who else what's up I know I'm just
running around to see who's gonna a
grove perch is looking for trouble
searching for it
keep up Kurt were you at okay this
area's back on fire okay let me look for
it all these areas back here unconquered
land it's assuming I can even get to
those places oh yeah there might be like
a locked or something
that question Mike area guy muscles well
I think you walked through it yeah okay
so walk through here okay so I feel like
we go over here somewhere maybe there
will be some people to fight whoa
yeah were you mmm where's the [ __ ]
where's the shove option let's start
[ __ ] but alright that guy looks stressed
this is cool the series oh I'm back
where I start this is the being okay oh
good that's right that's how it all
should be brats
alright so let's let's just go ahead and
assess where we're at here right so
we're trying to up north we're trying to
get out of here and go to the beautiful
island we have a bunch of side quests
available and then we have the main
quest story that's supposed to help us
out here so the in order to progress
here we have to make these metal dowels
but we need to level up our
craftsmanship but we don't get another
skill point until level 5 we're getting
there there's a lot of we have a lot of
balls in the air right now
exactly there's there's lots of you so I
shouldn't keep running this way we
should try to find he's our three quests
yeah I was like interrogate that guy
there's two smugglers they have to
interrogate so strange we couldn't find
them in that building or the other quest
was unmask the heretic the potion seller
guy which was also hilarious because we
gotta steal a bottle somehow
alright that's pretty lively walk cycle
I feel like of all of the ones the app
currently I'm trying to pair out which
cyclists would be the easiest yeah I
feel like they all bleed into each other
like we as they're called side quests
but like we had anything they helped out
the main mission I think
chan is saying just paid the bartender
we have enough money now oh that was an
option huh we were broke before it's
been a lot of coins on these dowels
which was also sad we were trying to do
it the honest way yeah I thought it
would be like I don't know here I got
the dowels but I guess I have to crap I
don't see what we can do now because I
don't have the craftsmanship about that
for the win doves in the chap things I
think we got all of that those points
though by bodying okay something would
have been cool we needed to get our
point across this part would first start
you gotta do the crafting skill first we
just threw hands what kind of business
do they run several actually and they're
all illegal when profitable no one is
around here but get him out of whatever
mess he's got himself into
seemed like a courageous fellow who
could down his pine beautiful islands
and that is it no oh yes my money on
those dowels hopefully they'll come in
later or come in handy later all the way
over here
me and maps whenever I play a game I'm
always pulling up for that yep the docks
ooh Kurt doesn't like the condition of
this dock I've gone too far
Kurt's bougie that's official oh boy
Oh oops
I thought I could like walk through the
air but there's no passage I got to go
up background all righty then where's it
you're trying to going out we are gonna
go find Constantine's right bartender
thing apparently he got so drunk he's
off in the docks that's probably him
right there on the Left hungover off in
this yeah
he's is he under visa a bunch of sacks I
hear him oh he's gonna get thrown out
that way your watch was right
it is Constantine's voice it's coming
from the floor above sounds as if he's
locked up and I have a feeling they're
expecting company or the slightest itchy
words are these boots will have them to
scratches floor now should may be the
solution as you say this breed of brutes
won't spit on ransom money what a waste
I'd rather sneak around them than give
off a kind to these seedy fellows we
already gave all our cool yeah bro all
right I'm sorry Kurt do you have another
$25
no it's my coin skirt I had to strike
down mini fo oh yeah and they were there
were some in those loot boxes to see
there we go little by little work this
game does have fighting in action
we had to earn it a little bit though in
the beginning stages I blew up that door
stealth attack in the beginning there
was some training and we had some scraps
along the way but right now we're on
some quests sneaker throw hands out of
kind now we're throwing hands all day
and we're stealing all their loot I'll
have the controls been so far um the
controls aren't bad I feel like the
camera to look around as a little
sensitive so like I'll go into certain
rooms I'll be like whoa whoa yeah that
door intro animation no lock-picking so
important ticket that's a pro strat you
guys are starting this game use your
skill tree point for the lock-picking
yeah 47 videos Hey there was already
like a ton of boxes I couldn't use Oh
indoors we can't open as I can get into
apparently I have a key oh there we go
we're still getting around 5 coins let's
hey more coins we're just robbing this
guy whoever's house the sits I know
we're like trying to find Constantine
but we're just getting paid instead
great I have to find the key I think
that's the next objective
the quest for Constantine and the key
have you found a key in one of those
boxes before I haven't not yet mm-hmm
oh there this that has to be it
yeah what's because of oh there we go
time to fight
oh boy Oh duck oh we're trying to help
headbutt this fool you know what he
cares about you I know
did you governor didn't do he is ridding
himself of a source of constant
disappointment
[Music]
got some inner turmoil going on he is
pumped to get out of here
companion equipment hey he's got one of
our squat hats dress yourselves when
also the people in your room oh now
we're whispering reasonable even though
he broke a bottle over your wrists and
started yelling at you I know but now we
have to be always pressing as long as he
has a hat I'm cool was I supposed to put
something specific
it's fine it's fine
now Kirk can hold his own so can
Constantine yeah let's go to the island
now shall we it's time we have our cabin
boy that's who we was looking for oh no
man oh I don't know big dude
nice wasn't an option we got this we're
a small army oh I got the key back from
the cell yeah
oh yeah we'll need it later I guess that
makes sense that they would all have one
cuz their guards all right hey you have
any skill three points was that lockpick
oh yeah wrong one okay different tree
[Music]
gives me more impede that would be ideal
broken and probably not something that's
in this early but
all right so let's go to that's it
that's that's where the ship is setting
sail so but we have to be real annoying
and go all the way around right let's do
this
the map actually looks bigger than it is
pretty big we've been uh it's like a
little maze like because there's it's
just built on like alleys it looks like
oh man that guy's dead oh that's like
water far I've gone way too far
yeah I'll look at the map and I'm like
that looks pretty far I make that same
mistake all the time I would
I'm always pressing start like and I
think I'm right there and I just walked
over it it's good to have a map though
no we don't deal with that merchants
anymore we're taking our business
alright we've gotten through the start
we're here Joker sweet now we can set
sail cause Constantine's finally here
anything else tattoo boy d'Orsay future
governor of tier Freddie I'm enchanted
captain I am eager to board your ship
enchanted as well your highness I hope
you enjoy your voyage are you ready
can we weigh anchor we should basically
wanna go to this island because it's
like the only place left that isn't
plagued by this crazy disease that they
don't know it right the cure maybe their
permission to board the ship we are
ready certainly but keep in mind that
we'll be at sea for several months oh
you have any farewells to make or any
fun business to put into order
No now we out cops we already time yep
perfect let's find the cure that guys
hadn't know you'll need to arm yourself
with patience the voyage will be long
I've been told the trip lasts months
I've always low-key enjoyed walking
right I could run right now if I wanted
to but I'm just like tilting the stick
sure just like you're going for the
cinematic feel oh they called me out
they were like look at all these side
quests you didn't do oh wow building the
creature was supposed to be out for days
now they're getting freaky I know he's
gonna burst out the boat they're about
to sail that big
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh first boss mate oh boy
run away dude we just got caught we just
found you dude I'd thank you
Oh monster did that to himself about the
solo this yeah what the heck you have
magic powers but they're magic all right
I have no choice
you got this versa everything you've
been training for
was a treat was pulled up from the
ground nice so we're gonna miss their
groups know chata same group or group
yep we let group grow up all the way
can't believe you're friends and left
you what's the point of having a party
you just gotta play the slow game
oh yeah broke his legs a value F in the
chat please wait did I not save this
whole time
it doesn't autosave what is hmm that's a
good question I think there's only 100
good that was right before the fight
yeah we had another shot at this people
it does autosave an it doesn't tell you
me I think if I just selected like load
last save point it but you probably
would say okay for sure I think I went
the long way around I was just scared at
first because I didn't save at any point
um the stream should be over now but I'm
not going out like no chump we're going
over time baby this is what we've been
waiting for is I just like this we were
gonna be like alright thanks for tuning
in and we skipped in this is it babe
sequence yeah thank you for all the apps
oh and even one waster okay
there we go oh nice block run faster
that hat is really aerodynamic so does
your magic power Oh doesn't just
regenerate on its own okay good you got
this
the calcium but it's fine but I need the
Sprint motion here he's not stressing
anymore whoa good block like that is
that jumping backwards animation Harry
hey no oh oh that was all bad
he's like he stuns me a little bit on
dude
I don't know if it'll help but r3 says
select target that like locks the camera
if you want that who
okay hold up we need a break practical
pause here for my peace of mind
thanks very much woo little breather he
did better great he was so close more
EPS in the chat please thank you more
EPS for my life oh my gosh I'm not going
out like that chat oh this is the last
time I'm gonna change okay I think you
got this you've been close and you got
even closer I think this is it cuz you
know I'm too scared to do the combo like
the this like square square square
triangle cuz this triangle she like goes
in I don't want to be that you know
finisher no fear razors real nice
technical cause yeah I know we needed it
it was more of a mental pause we needed
who yeah don't forget that boy you're
good at the block
oh man
nope
Otacon you got to get in there and smack
fruit we're trying baby we got this r33
that is suggesting our three it will
it'll lock the camera looks like they're
yes is it okay cool
Pro strats Pro shot my oh my mana
recharge real quick actually I saw some
good oh good you use potions and a
tactical pause
oh there you go you're good you're good
oh that sweep I hate that be good block
took no help off yet we're in overtime
now baby why was she not drinking the
potion okay I hit the pudding three
times oh you did yes oh I might have
been out actually don't like drink the
potion woman a good battle nonetheless
that was exciting this is not that hard
I'm just gonna throw it out there right
now it's not this is just me you come
prepared with potions maybe that's the
secret extra potions okay for real last
time however almost had them we're going
into third overtime oh dang oh dang I'm
all over the place it's like thank you
appreciate all the others there's like
the ever-so-slight estill a from when
you like run and when like it actually
starts up oh sorry he didn't hit you
don't forget our 351
there you go
hit and run just like chat says hit take
a little break run away although when
you're really party does that body
dragging thing just really scary there
you go keep the blocks ready nice yes
yeah that start off on the run it's like
just run
[Music]
nothing not a scratch on you meanwhile
he's that house no no he got good block
good block that thing normally takes
half your help good block oh there you
go he just missed that one scare a deer
block he does that thing whoa
good luck pull that pulled right now no
I think the whole pressing up on the
d-pad it says yes you got it
you're a full help you got this you got
this
good block is almost down I wasn't
giving enough respect to the pairing the
period the periods actually way better
than I do
carry it's just a circle okay yeah just
respect the parry oh look at this it's
like a movie what a savage finishes
Aaron black yes oh where were you Kurt
I know Thanks what the hell Kurt could
have used yes don't touch me all this
because I just wanna see it's here for
you before we went into triple overtime
so you got it you got the win you did
all the work could be so modest truly
Yeah right
we're gonna in bit here if you guys
enjoyed what she saw today then
greenfile will be available tomorrow ps4
Xbox one and PC this is going the
beginning yeah keep in mind there's
still so much game left and we didn't
even get to like the real meat and
potatoes at the story yeah there's a lot
to be had with the skill tree and stuff
obviously a big meal to chew on here
and I'm enjoying it so far so I'm
actually interested in playing some more
of it myself and actually you know
figuring out the combat system a little
bit more because I feel like I have yet
to unlock the really cool stuff I've
seen in the trailer yep like we said
this is literally the beginning of the
story that really turned it up a notch
for me though yeah yeah great alright
guys well thanks so much for tuning in I
hope you enjoyed the first hour plus of
greed fall and hope that you may me pick
one up for yourself if you enjoyed what
you saw so we will catch guys the next
time see you later bye